history of the american empire next
sunday at noon eastern only on book tv
ron collins when you first start to
explain lenny bruce in your book you
call his humor
unsettling how did you choose come upon
that word
unsettling um
lenny bruce is an equal opportunity
offender
um i think if you listen to lenny
bruce's comedy long enough
whatever your political stripes liberal
conservative left right centrist
sooner or later
he'll get to you he got to me
and so it unsettling just seemed like a
you know kind of a
unsettling uninhibited
on anything
you know really that kind of captures if
you just add on to anything that's lenny
bruce what was your first experience
with him actually you know i um
born in 1949 i when i was very very very
young if i had stuck into a club on some
adult's coattail i might have caught
lenny bruce uh but what what was your
first experience with him with his work
um actually i didn't listen to him
didn't you nadine stross of the aclu
years ago had sent me something
and
i read about this dead comic and my
interest is in first amendment law i
taught it and worked in the area and
although i heard lenny bruce i never
knew that benny bruce
and the first amendment had anything
and i thought this is an incredible
story and everything i'd ever read about
law i had never once i mean lady bruce
was comedy there was comedy here there
was a law here
and so when nadine strassen sent me
some information about lenny bruce in
his trial i was astonished i how come
this was never on my radar screen how
could i have missed this i mean i live
drink eat sleep this stuff how did this
and one thing led to another and another
and another and i called it my friend
david skover who's a law professor
and the more we dug the more incredible
it was and we thought this is a story
that hasn't been told that is lenny
bruce and free speech
and it was the beginning of the trials
of lena cruz tell us the story
uh the story of the writing of the story
everybody started it story of lenny
bruce when was he born um lenny bruce he
dies in 66
uh born in the 20s
dies on august 3 1966 which is one of
the great moments in pop culture history
died of an overdose
his early years
in comedy
just kind of a comedian trying to find
himself uh out of upstate new york
jewish
uh borch belt um
and really it's when when lenny bruce
realizes for the first time in the late
50s
uh that there's something to be told
other than mother-in-law jokes you know
one-liners
and basically what lenny did is he
his comedy dealt with taboo political
taboo religious taboo sexual taboo
anything that wasn't being said out in
the open but everybody lived in their
daily lives this made for lenny bruce's
comedy
is what made him great it's what put him
on steve allen's show who very much
defended him throughout his career
but um
you know when you
when you come after the gods when you go
after the brokers of power
sooner or later they swat back
and with lenny bruce they swat back
in san francisco at the jazz workshop
where he was arrested for his comedy
at the gate of horn in chicago
uh at the troubadour in los angeles and
then at the cafe gogo in new york what
were the charges the same thing
obscenity dirty words
i mean these were private clubs
for adults only um they were all new
nobody was taken by surprise
but it wasn't just foul-mouthed comedy
it was irreverent speech
it was speech that attacked as i said
the brokers of power they may have been
bishops they may have been presidents
they may have been you know authority
figures
but one way or another lenny bruce went
after all of them and each time he did
whether or not it was in the liberal san
francisco the jazz workshop
or in the liberal corridors in in
chicago
at um at the gate of horn
it's fact now i think almost all the
venues he was prosecuted in were quote
progressive places
uh and at the end the trial in new york
went on
for months and months and months and
months and this man whose income in the
late 50s and early 60s had reached 200
000 which is an astonishing amount for
the time when he died he was bankrupt
the trial in new york how did it come
about
lenny bruce is played performing at a
place um called the cafe go go
everything in those days was a go-go you
might remember you know so the cafe go
go consistent with the time was a go-go
and uh he went there and
part of his comedy
was some comedy that i think was
tasteless it came after the kennedy
assassination
and
that combined with all his attacks on
the church and political figures and
what have you
and
the police were in the audience when
lenny bruce used to perform in the back
of the audience men in blue stood there
two four six eight
ready just ready
and all they needed to trigger
the arrest was a dirty word
but what really offended them in los
angeles in san francisco in new york and
chicago weren't the words
the real offense was the message
and that's where the first event comes
in
i mean if the first amendment cannot
protect things that offend us
then why have it
and
in some places lenny prevailed he
prevailed in san francisco
where a jury found him not guilty
ultimately he prevailed in illinois when
the case went all the way and by the way
he's paying for these attorneys all the
time norm he had 25 attorneys you know
in the course of all these attorney
prosecutions some names we know today uh
well some of the people who prosecuted
him right there yeah yeah
okay
well i don't know how
we
do want to respect the debt on the other
hand we respect them by telling the
truth one of his prosecutors out of los
angeles california a young man named
johnny cochran
it just shows that in those days it was
fashionable uh to come after uh
comedians who said the sort of things
that i did now to his credit uh johnny
later in life uh unlike some other
prosecutors in the case looked back and
said it was a mistake
you know knowing what i know now knowing
what i how much i value the first
amendment knowing what the first
amendment means when it says no right no
means no for the government
i shouldn't have done it
as it turns out it was a case that
johnny cochran lost uh when he won that
case um
but you know if you just
the last comedian in american history
the last one and may it never happened
again but the last one to be prosecuted
for word crimes
in a comedy club i'm just talking about
words i'm not talking about nude acts or
anything like that it was lenny bruce
after lenny bruce died on august 3rd
1966
never again not once any place in the
deep south and the enlightened east you
know the laid back west no place you
know
did it happen again
it's not like the supreme court had
ruled on high the supreme court has
never ruled on this issue
but the culture
after lenny died
the man who died bankrupt penniless
nobody interested in the foul mouth
comedian and when he died
he stood convicted in new york his
conviction had never
he was appealing it but he died before
the appeal ran so he died a convicted
man
and so when he died lenny browse was
died of you know pitiless foul-mouthed
communion but as it turned out death was
his best publicity agent you have a
photo of george carlin in your book why
george carlin was at the gate of horn uh
the night in chicago the night lenny
bruce was busted there
fabulous story uh and
judge george carlin i said judge
sorry george uh judge carlin talk about
something the lefenda man calling call a
comedian judge um
he was in the audience that night young
man a big lenny bruce fan and uh so
letty had taken on the church that night
and there were some
some irish catholic uh
big police in the back they were not
gonna take uh lenny disenta pope that
was just it actually for all practical
purposes he was arrested for blasphemy i
mean that wasn't the formal charge but
what really triggered it was his
irreverence toward the pope
and so george
george collins is there you know one
drink after another and the more he
drinks the more he enjoys the comedy
and so when the police came to him uh
they wanted to see everybody's id and
they asked him for id
the cocky kind of guy is by his own
admission he says i don't believe in id
i don't believe in it
so
these cops were not going to take any
got from him
so uh
they hauled him off
and lo and behold there's a paddy wagon
and in the paddy wagon
lenny bruce you know the grounds you
know man and this young you know
uh guy us um
and so it's almost like a lady bruce
routine he says what are you in here for
george garland tells him
and he says you know you schmuck i can't
believe you're in here for that and so
uh so the young george carlin a little
moment uh and you see later on in
carlin's life that lenny bruce
definitely had a very significant
influence on him
when the argument came in front in the
new york court
why did he why did he lose there was a
couple of courts by the way one time uh
lenny believe it or not
he had one of his cases in the new york
court of in this court of appeals
federal court of appeals for the second
circuit and one of the people there
uh as he was arguing this case was
thurgood marshall believe it or not he
was then on the
didn't persuade uh thurgood on that day
but uh then uh late in his career after
um
he's been tried uh for using these foul
words uh in the cafe a go-go and then
his case um
is goes in the appellate courts in his
court his case was pending there were
two cases there the man who owned the
capital gogo and lenny bruce's
lenny bruce while for all practical
purposes while that case is pending he
leaves new york with the intent of never
returning
so
he probably
had he ever returned would have been
taken off to rikers
while this case is pending
he dies of an overdose
and about that time the man who owned
the copy of gogo it was found
that the speech that lenny bruce had
engaged in was protected by the first
amendment which means had lenny bruce
lived
but he didn't live
and since 1966
until 2003
that conviction stood on the books
um
and that was something having written
the book that i just felt had to be
corrected so with david scover the two
of us
this was this part of the book yeah well
we we we
when we wrote the book we never thought
of petitioning government
no no no we just got involved and then
we thought my god this conviction is on
the books
i mean it's a precedent it says it's
okay to punish comedians for these sorts
of word crimes and you know as people
concerned about free speech values we
just thought this can't
this can't remain this has to be undone
right this is unsettling to us if you
will
and so um
the two of us uh worked together with an
attorney named robert cormivir
and he did all of the legal work and we
helped him and we petitioned the
governor and it was kind of like a howl
you know
this is just something we have to do all
right and it never occurred to us in our
wildest dreams that governor pataki
uh would do anything we didn't think he
would say yes we didn't think he would
say no we just thought he'd completely
ignore it but he did
on december 23rd i get a phone call and
it says in a few minutes it's bob robert
corner the lawyer who wrote it he says
in a few minutes your phone is going to
be just going crazy
governor pataki has pardoned lenny bruce
i must say i i never thought i would see
the day did he give a reason uh yeah
he did he did i mean here's a republican
governor in state of new york he just
said you know this was wrong this was a
violation of our first amendment this
was something that had the record had to
be cleared and so at the end of the day
um
we have a president we have a precedent
for freedom and what the courts didn't
do the governor of new york did and i'm
happy and uh i i said it caught us
completely by surprise it's a nice
ending to a story back up to to the time
in which he was being arrested how did
the media treat him in different parts
of the country oh um well when you're
you know when you're skyrocketing to
fame everybody's with you right
but
but when the floor implodes you know you
go alone no the first amendment issue
some of the people you know least
concerned in the history of this country
about violations of first amendment with
all due respect in the media i mean you
know in the print press it was not a
single editorial not a single editorial
anywhere anywhere in lenny bruce's
lifetime that came in any major paper i
should say uh certainly the alternative
newspapers uh the free press in new york
i mean in los angeles but uh no uh and
if anything whatever turtles there were
were critical
uh
and and um
look
freedom involves risks
and when you take your risk you're going
to offend people and when you offend
people more often than not you're
standing alone and that's what's
happening with lenny bruce i mean only a
handful of people
phil spector
um
was was there steve allen
um
ant-man from playboy magazine hugh
hefner hugh hefner was
stood by lenny bruce from beginning to
end when things were good when things
were bad uh
and um
and it shows his commit to the first
amendment as well to what degree did his
narcotics use
influence
the way the country looked at him and
looked at his case yeah uh
a dark angel
like joplin like hendrix like morris and
like all these guys
in one sense in one sense drugs
liberated him
it allowed him to toy with taboo
um
but
the dark angel knocks and nak she did
um
prozac hadn't been invented yet lenny
bruce was very much the victim of
depression
um
and
he started um injecting that depression
right into his veins
and it took him
uh i mean by the time he dies in in
august of 1966 everything is going wrong
i mean he's a fugitive from new york no
place will allow him to perform he's out
of money they're about to repossess his
house he's about to go into bankruptcy i
mean
everything has just turned black black
black
and fact there's not even any respect
for the dead when he dies
you know he's on he's on he's on his
bathroom floor he's naked syringe in his
arm
and for hours and hours and hours
the police allowed the press to come in
and photograph after photograph and film
after film i mean there was no respect
even when he died i mean they treated
him like he was a mobster a gangster
like dillinger you know that sort of
thing do you think if he hadn't used the
kennedy assassination work in his in his
work
that um it might have been different was
that
well certainly that was that was what
pro
from what we know uh that's what
caught the attention of the prosecutors
in new york but you say well if you'd
taken this out of your act
well but if it wasn't x it would have
been why
i mean i mean remember i mean a lot of
lenny bruce's uh audience were
progressive jews but then lenny comes
out and does a bit about eichmann you
know
you know a lot of them were progressives
and then he starts talking about race
and using the n-word but in order to
make a point with lenny it was always to
make a point you know he says take
poverty out of the equation take
prejudice out of the equation uh
take power out of the equation there's
nothing left for me to criticize there's
nothing left that i will have no work i
have no function there's no comedy and
so it was that combination of the
political
and the comic which at the end turned
out to be tragic
um but like i said once lenny bruce dies
death was his best for business i mean
within a year after he dies his records
are selling millions there's books
coming at him dustin hoffman's making a
movie about him
and all of a sudden the phoenix rises
now somebody maybe under the age of 20
watching this interview would be
confused because they probably see
any number of comedians
doing what he was prosecuted for
today
is it is it different well first of all
remember we're talking about a comedy
club right a club that we're not talking
about television in hong kong we're just
a comedy club where adults come and
adults listen to adult fair that's a big
difference
um
i think too
with lenny it wasn't dirty jokes just
for dirty jokes sakes you know
the words were part of a larger message
all right
the message itself was offensive um
and the words helped fuel that
why would you ridicule power
religious power political power economic
power so i think there was a big
difference between
a lot of the comedy today we hear was
just foul words for their own sake not
that you know the first amendment
doesn't have a role there too but with
lenny bruce it was a little different
when did you decide to uh include a cd
well when source books published the
book we're writers we do writing we do
that's what we do i mean we
ears you know video all that was that
something we did and they said look we
want to have a cd
and
so on the cd which
um has actual lenny bruce doing his bits
that he got arrested for lenny if you
can believe this in his trial in new
york was so typical lenny bruce he
brings in a briefcase with a little tape
recorder in and he's taping the
proceedings and so on the cd you hear
the prosecutor actually cross-examining
some of the witnesses oh had lenny had
the judge found that out definitely
contempt no doubt about it
um
and
we were particularly honored uh when nat
hinto agreed to narrate it nat the man
who wrote the linear notes on early bob
dylan albums the miles davis albums let
nat who knew lenny
lenny bruce uh he knew him in the early
days he was at his trial i mean you know
just first-hand experience uh when nat
hentoff who was a great defender of the
first amendment wrote for the village
voice both for the village voice knew
him there still very much alive and
still very much cantankerous and out
there protecting our first amendment
values well we were honored it was a
great honor when he agreed
to narrate the cd what do you do for a
living i work for the first amendment
center which is why we're an educational
group uh now in washington dc we're part
of the freedom forum and our purpose is
to educate the american public
about our five freedom speech press
petition assembly religion we don't sue
people we don't lobby our mission is
simply an educational one what's the
biggest first amendment case out there
right now well right now it's the one
that's in the united states supreme
court the bonds for jesus case
involving student expression and if
lenny bruce were alive i'm sure this
would make for a great routine
ron collins is the author the book is
called the trials of lenny bruce the
fall and rise of an american icon thank
you one thing i'd like to add sure with
david scover michael
thank you
podcasts or download them from itunes
next christine hefner former ceo and
chair of playboy enterprises talks about
comedian lenny bruce's life and legacy
ms hefner focuses on bruce's use of
social commentary in his stand-up
routines and how he pushed the
boundaries of free speech
this keynote address is part of a
two-day conference commemorating the
recent acquisition of lenny bruce's
archival collection at brandeis
university
it's about 30 minutes
i'm here also to offer special thanks to
steve krief
who was sitting over here
who is the other in a sense instigator
and driving force of this conference
steve wrote a
enormously rich enormously informative
biography and sort of career study of
lenny bruce
done in 2005 at the university of paris
and um as a result of his research in
that respect he got to
meet and got to know lenny bruce's
daughter and it was really steve who
suggested to kitty
that
brandeis university would be the ideal
site for the papers of her father
so this would not really happen at all
we none of us would be here without
steve's initiative and instigation and i
want to thank you
really for that
you'll be hearing from steve later this
morning of course as well as as well as
this afternoon when he will be in
conversation with katie bruce
i was not privy to that conversation in
which steve suggested that brandeis was
the ideal
site for that but i'd like to
imagine what the argument that steve
offered might have been we start with
the most obvious which is that we are
named for louis brandeis the same
initials as lenny bruce that's the
that's the least significant feature
but
we're an unusual somewhat unusual
university of course because we're not
named for a benefactor we're not named
for a donor however grateful we are for
our benefactors and our donors
renamed for a supreme court justice who
himself was one of on the half dozen or
a short list of those
who articulated really the case for
maximizing freedom of expression
uh one of the supreme court justices
most important for
in a sense grasping and for most fully
appreciating the significance of the
first amendment itself
and particularly in his concurring
opinion in whitney versus california
justice brandeis basically made about as
strong a case as anybody has ever made
for the connection between the sense of
autonomy the sense of dignity the sense
of self-respect
that has to be connected with the
impulse to express oneself
and how that need for self-expression is
also deeply connected to any sort of
imaginable
dynamic and flourishing democracy
so that is a tradition that we at the
university are very proud of
and of course i don't need to tell
anybody in this audience the connection
to lenny bruce himself
um and that lenny bruce was himself a
figure who
in some ways even went beyond the the
boundaries of nightclub comedy and
performance
in pursuit of uh
maximal self-expression one of his own
favorite expressions was the yiddish
term ms truth
a variation of the on the hebrew emmett
truth which is in the bran the bran the
official brand i seal
so there's that connection in a sense as
well
and just as lenny bruce himself near the
end of his life
um seemed to even burst the bounds
boundaries of comedy
and to say very famously quote i'm not a
comedian i'm lenny bruce and of quote
was a way of indeed pushing that effort
at truthfulness
uh so that these are at least some of
the arguments that steve might have
presented to kitty um as to why um uh
there's a special significance why the
the archives are available here
and that brings me to the pleasure of
introducing our keynote speaker
because there are also those particular
sorts
really of connections as well
christy heffner graduated from brandeis
as ron has mentioned as you know from
also from the program graduated phi beta
kappa in english and american literature
as the department was known at the time
and has since then been an
extraordinarily loyal extraordinarily
dedicated alumna
and supporter of the university and we
are deeply appreciative christie of
the allegiance really that you've shown
to the university in the in the
succeeding decades
there's a historical reason as well
and that is that in the mid 1950s to the
late 1950s
playboy was crucial in
in a sense jump starting the careers of
three major comedians
mort saul dick gregory and of course
lenny bruce
and in that sense playboy played an
extraordinary role in the transformation
of american comedy
away from simply
and i'm not disparaging it away from
simply gags the ratatat efforted jokes
toward a sort of personal effort at
pursuing ms at pursuing truth
and in that sense there's an historic
role here that
that christy hefner and her family have
really played in that particular change
toward something that would indeed alter
the direction really of american comedy
and pursue it in
the directions that would allow
the understanding really of perhaps
uncomfortable truths whether they be
racial whether they be sexual whether
they be political
and finally uh the argument for um
christie hefner as our commencement as
our keynote speaker
is also the sense that her own career
both in philanthropy and in her own
politics
has also represented a rather gallant
dedication
to both the promotion of and the
protection of the first amendment
so it is with great pleasure and it's a
great honor for me to invite christy
hefner to be our keynote speaker
[Applause]
thank you steve very much
i actually wasn't quite old enough to
have had a seminal impact in the late
50s
and in
the sort of wonderful way that
synchronicity happens
i actually had nothing to do with the
gift that my father made i was not
involved in those conversations
and in some regards that makes it more
sweet because instead of feeling that
i needed to be an actor
to facilitate it it happened because all
of the parties saw it as steve so
eloquently put
it as something that was meant to be
with many points of intersection and
many connections
steve in terms of points of connection
was telling me last night that this is
the last semester that he's going to be
teaching at brandeis and he started
teaching when i was a student so i think
that's a very nice arc and i want to
thank you for all that you have done
because your fingerprints are all over
this and it would not have been possible
without you
[Applause]
and i also want to thank kitty who i've
known over the years and
who makes it a particular pleasure to be
able to be a part of this to share this
together
we share the experience of having iconic
fathers
but beyond that we're going to talk
over the next two days about the legacy
of lenny bruce
kitty is the legacy of lenny bruce and
it was kitty's vision and passion and
fierce protectiveness that preserved all
those papers and all those extraordinary
recordings and then had the generosity
of spirit to make it available not just
to her family but to all of us and we
owe her a deep deep debt so thank you
i lastly want to thank youtube with whom
we've partnered which is going to allow
many more people than those in this room
to listen in on the next two days and to
participate and
even as you heard today in meeting steve
from paris
lenny himself his life his work his
struggles and the issues raised by all
of those
are contemporary and global and the more
we can amplify the audience engaged in
that conversation the better
so these days we talk a lot about being
in an age of disruption
airbnb in hotels
netflix and blockbuster
uber and taxis
amazon and retailers
and it's true that much of what
consumers and businesses knew even 15
years ago has dramatically changed
but while the technologies and
globalization have accelerated change in
our times
we actually think about the fact that
being disruptive and provocative
is not unique to our times and was very
much a defining element of the late 50s
and the early 60s
it's been said
the times they were changing
and perhaps what's most striking about
those times when we compare them to
today
is that the
changes were less about business models
and actually more about ideas and values
about conformity and hypocrisy
and the challengers were less often
entrepreneurs and more often activists
and artists
it's easy to lose sight of what america
looked like in post-world war ii era
the man in the
the man in the gray flannel suit
the happy housewife
the traditional family that was started
in the early twenties
the eisenhower years
an age of conformity
but underneath that placid surface a lot
of pent-up demand for change was roiling
the feminine mystique
the civil rights movement
the beat generation
a growing questioning of government
a questioning of traditional attitudes
about sex and reproduction
through the impact of the gi bill by
1960 the united states became the first
society to have more college students
than farmers
the country was poised for a
generational prison break
and these non-traditional ideas were
being expressed in all media
in art in poetry in music and film in
books and magazines
there was a space opening up in the
culture
more oxygen in the air
it was a distinct moment for the
transgressive
the avant-garde
versus the old guard
born leonard alfred schneider in 1925
lenny bruce died 50 years ago
at the age of 40.
but in his short life he became a
superstar
and in the years since then his fame and
influence have only grown
comedy central ranked him the third
greatest comedian of all time
following richard pryor and george
carlin
two clear successors to lenny's
groundbreaking work
as steve alluded to previous generations
of comedians jack benny bob hope milton
berle
had a style of telling rapid fire jokes
a brief setup followed by a punchline
and lenny's style couldn't have been
more different
he wrote his own material
rooted in personal experiences
targeting the hypocrisy of contemporary
society
along with the others of his time like
mort saul and dick gregory and elaine
may and mike nichols
he was more a comic thinker than a
comedian
and as steve mentioned all of those
people had some connection to playboy
featured in the magazine or performing
in the playboy clubs or on playboy's
penthouse the syndicated television show
my father hosted
a show was in a side that got no
carriage in the south because its format
was to feature black performers in front
of an integrated audience on the set
there were many points of intersection
between lenny and my father which really
led up to the logic of the human hefner
foundation making the grant that
facilitated this acquisition
playboy was launched in december of 1953
and my father envisioned it as a
guidebook for the urban mail that would
combine lifestyle information with
entertainment and thoughtful and
provocative great writing both fiction
and non-fiction
it was underpinned though by a
philosophy a philosophy that centered
around the critical importance of
personal freedom and individual rights
and as a result of that heff and the
magazine were especially interested in
the other rebels of that time
they published for example jack kiriwak
and fahrenheit 451
they assigned alex haley to conduct the
very first playboy interview which was
with miles davis who spent a good deal
more time talking about race than music
they broke with the norman rockwell
tradition of straightforward
illustration to feature the work of
great artists like roger brown and andy
warhol
they launched an annual jazz poll and
organized a playboy jazz festival in
chicago in 1959 to benefit the urban
league
heff first met lenny in 1958 when he
went to san francisco to hear him
perform this was shortly after lenny was
really breaking through with new
material and a new style of delivery
that was allowing him to play in
nightclubs that were not also strip
clubs
hef was so impressed that he contacted
friends who owned the gate of horn club
in chicago and arranged for lenny to
play there
the illinois obscenity statute had
recently been amended to
reflect the 1957 supreme court roth
decision so many people were feeling
that clubs nightclubs were really free
speech zones
lenny went on to play mr kelly's in
chicago and that led to his being
interviewed by studs turkle
the next year the magazine profiled him
in an article entitled rebel with a
caustic cause
in the early 60s he appeared on
playboy's penthouse and then the
magazine first excerpted and then the
company published his autobiography how
to talk dirty and influence people
many times he stayed at the chicago
playboy mansion when he was in town
i would say like contemporary art and
contemporary jazz
heff doug lenny
but lenny was more than a gifted
disruptive artist experimenting with
extremes like a jackson pollock or a
miles davis
lenny became a martyr
heff also knew what it was like to be
persecuted
the magazine was denied its second class
postal permit and had to go to court to
win it
that 1959 jazz festival i told you about
was supposed to be at soldier field but
the catholic church pressured the first
mayor daley to pull the permit
in later years hef would be on nixon's
enemies list a source of great pride
and the company would go to court to
challenge reagan's mise commission which
was pressuring retailers not to sell the
magazine congress for defunding the
braille yes the braille edition of
playboy
and a bill
that was attempting to limit all of
cable to the broadcast network standards
which resulted in a supreme court
victory codifying that cable standards
would be the same as print and online
in another small world connection that
case was argued by bobcorn revere
bob would go on to successfully petition
the state of new york for lenny's pardon
in 2003
and that inspired ron collins's book the
trials of lenny bruce
that book would win a hugh m hefner
first amendment award
but in playboy's battles heff not only
had great lawyers including some like
harry calvin who also represented lenny
on a pro bono basis
in heft's battles he had a large company
behind him and a powerful platform in
the magazine
lenny had none of that
just friends
and hef was one of those friends
a friend who believed in lenny and who
stood with him in the good times the bad
times the unpopular times and all times
because alone among the many rebellious
artists talented men and women who were
his contemporaries
lenny bruce was persecuted and
prosecuted for his words and his ideas
because he confronted the hypocrisy of
institutions and of society
because he was willing to criticize and
challenge stereotypes he became a target
fundamentally he was busted over and
over and over again
for blasphemy
but because blasphemy is not against the
law he was prosecuted for obscenity
lenny bruce was very much an artist of
his times
time magazine called him the elvis of
comedy
it was often noted that his monologues
were delivered in the rhythms of a jazz
musician most famously perhaps his too
is a preposition come is a verb
but at the same time i believe that his
relevance and resonance today couldn't
be greater
while it is a tragedy for lenny and his
family
that he died so young
in some ways his best years came after
his death
because he has left us with a critically
important legacy that will begin to be
explored over the next two days by two
dozen distinguished scholars and
thinkers
for my part i would observe the
following
we live in a time when lenny's comic
bloodlines have flourished like never
before
much of the comedy we hear today was
pioneered by lenny
comedy that similarly challenges and
channels the contemporary zeitgeist
that includes not only great male comics
like lewis black who will hear tonight
but incredible female comics like sarah
silverman and amy schumer
today comedians as a matter of course
employ their personal lives and voices
to comment on society its mores its
values
when we listen to stephen colbert or
john oliver or jon stewart
we're going to them not just for comedy
but for critical perspective
just like listening to lenny made us
both laugh and think
and sometimes it also made us squirm
because a part of lenny's genius was how
he related to an audience
how he created for them and with them
the experience of being overcome with
laughter
over that which was both hilarious and
transgressive
in a time of the charlie hebdo murders
we would do well to be thoughtful about
the role of humor in human affairs
and to think about what our perhaps
unacknowledged the off-limits of today
as marty garbas has said and we are very
fortunate to be hearing from him later
today
quote the history of the law of free
expression is one of vindication in
cases involving speech that many
citizens find shabby offensive or even
ugly end quote
after all we don't need a first
amendment to protect popular speech
the first amendment is unique to america
and in theory widely admired
but so much of our discourse about
freedom of speech is abstract
starting with the fact that it's
important to understand that free speech
and the first amendment
are not the same thing
the first amendment is necessary but not
sufficient
almost everyone attempting to limit free
expression starts by saying i'm not for
censorship but
as hugo black noted we must not be
afraid to be free
we should be asking ourselves what is
transgressive at this moment and how do
we not just protect but nurture it
we come together on the campus of a
great university founded in the name of
a brilliant jurist who established the
standard for the only kind of speech
that i believe should be banned
that which is intended and likely to
cause immediate violence
let's be careful that our more developed
sensitivities around inclusion and
diversity
don't turn into ways to protect people
and especially students from challenging
ideas
as robert zimmer president of the
university of chicago has said quote
universities cannot be viewed as a
sanctuary for comfort
but rather as a crucible for confronting
ideas and thereby learning to make
informed judgments in complex
environments
in the 60s students were demanding the
right to free speech now at least some
students demand the right to be free
from speech that they find to be
offensive upsetting or emotionally
disturbing
and while private universities like
private companies such as facebook and
twitter are not bound by the first
amendment
i share the belief of jeffrey rosen
legal scholar and head of the national
constitution center that they would do
well to resist pressure to moderate
speech or content in the name of
promoting civility
as salman rushdie someone who certainly
knows firsthand what it means to offend
has said quote
what is freedom of expression
without the freedom to offend it ceases
to exist
this conference is extremely timely as
during this election season much has
been noted about the need for greater
civility in our politics and in the
media
i concur
i too worry that whereas a different
race or religion used to be the greatest
concern of parents regarding who their
child would marry
now it's political affiliation
and whereas back in the 60s everybody
watched the same tv shows and read the
same magazines now it's so easy to be
balkanized and choose to only be exposed
to those ideas and points of view that
we agree with and that agree with us
yet even as we work towards a more civil
union
let's be sure that we remain equally
committed to that transgressive idea and
ideal that underpinned lenny's work
that nothing is sacrosanct
everything is open to being questioned
and challenged and even mocked
because that is also what underpins our
democracy
when lenny was pardoned back in 2003 it
was said in fact
that pardon was for the rest of us
let's be sure we earned it
thank you
[Applause]
great
sorry could you just use the mic if you
wait because then it'll get recorded
the library of congress keeps playboy
magazine in the rare book room which is
a very strange place if you've ever done
any research there it got very thick
carpets and very polished tables and all
some years ago when i was doing some
research on stand-up comedy
i had opportunity to go down there and
look at because playboy published uh an
interview with mort saul lenny bruce
jules pfeiffer and i forget who uh oh
and jonathan winters and i wanted to use
that material
so i went up uh to the library congress
rare book room and
the librarian very aggressively said
what do you want that for
and i said i don't have to tell you that
i said i'm a professor at the university
of maryland and even if i weren't
as a us citizen i have access to this
so she brings the volume
and then she does a lot of dusting to
kind of watch what i was doing
and so i waited till she got with an eye
shot and i turned around to the center
fold i started taking notes
she's probably still reeling from that
thank you
yes
this isn't really a question but i just
want to say that uh
this is really a good thing
this is happening
you know i was thinking the other day at
the end of his life
i mean the day he died
the bank of america foreclosed on his
house
he hadn't worked in a long time in his
you know he could get an occasional
concert
and that was it you know
and
you know i'm told i've read
that he was
afraid at the end that no one would
remember
and i think it's wonderful
that
50 years after his death
at a northeastern ivy league school
which is about as far from lenny bruce's
hollywood as it's possible to get in the
continental united states here we are
gathering
to discuss
his i mean a scholarly discussion on his
life
on his career and a celebration of his
life
i i tend not to refer to lenny bruce
as a comedian
i call him a humorist
because in my opinion he's right up
there with mark twain
robert benchley will rogers
the best of them you know and i think
he's the most
important humorist of the 20th century
and thank you again my name is tom
deegan nice to meet you thank you
[Applause]
can you please elaborate a little bit on
what you see are the dangers um uh to in
free speech on the campuses uh
whether it's limits of of uh too much
political correctness and things like
that so just want you to elaborate on
that a little bit please sure um i
quoted
president zimmer i live in chicago
and i think
all universities are grappling with this
and where's greg
so stand up greg
so greg is the founder and head of an
organization called fire
and we've worked together through the
foundation and around first amendment
and you should make a point of finding
greg after
this session when we're on coffee break
because
we used to support and still do the
student press law center which is a
really wonderful organization that has
worked on behalf of the rights of
students
in
whether they're working on their school
newspaper or
they're organizing on campus
because
many of us feel that there's a double
harm when you
censor you know student speech or
student journalists the first is the
censorship itself but the second is the
message that you're sending to people
who
are in a learning environment
which is so contrary to the message you
want to send them
fire now is is aggressively also working
in that space and greg can tell you a
lot about individual cases but i
mentioned uh president zimmer because
a friend of mine jeff stone who's a
distinguished constitutional lawyer and
actually wrote a book called free speech
in perilous times that won a human
hefner award a few years ago
was tasked by the university to write a
kind of a
mission statement that would express the
university's view that
it
would not and could not and should not
trade off its commitment to freedom of
expression
for
comfort for students while at the same
time being respectful of different
voices and that
kind of mission statement if you will or
code is being adopted by a number of
other schools and i think they're
striking the right balance but i
think that we have all seen examples in
the press
of
of the heckler's veto of
disinvitations to controversial speakers
and
as i tried to
reference in my own remarks
you know i am like everybody else
gratified by the
continuing advancement in our society of
respect for diversity and inclusion and
tolerance that wasn't always there
so
holding on to those values is important
but where they actually run up against
the right of free expression is i think
the moment where we have to say
the best
antidote to speech that we not only
don't agree with but we find distasteful
or even hateful is more speech
[Applause]
i want to raise the jewish question
uh lenny bruce allowed me and many of my
contemporaries in the 1950s and 60s to
re-identify with the jewish experience
and my first article ever published was
lenny bruce a jewish humorist in babylon
right now i'm working on a film
uh
inspired by your father
it's called taking sides it's a film
about lenny bruce
mort saul and dick gregory and i'm
wondering why
the foundation hasn't considered a
similar kind of film
because our young people today given the
polluted political atmosphere
that
has come into the discourse
i think we need to reawaken
consciousness of lenny bruce mort soul
and dick gregory yeah well the
foundation isn't a filmmaker but they're
they have given grants to films
wonderful films from the celluloid
closet which sort of traced the history
of representation of homosexuality and
uh film to um uh
gosh the atomic cafe so
all i would say in answer to the direct
question is
if you are working on a film you should
make an application for support from the
foundation and you're quite right that
all three of those
people
had a very deep connection to playboy
and in fact dick gregory who's kind of a
casual friend
is
unbelievably generous and outspoken
about how he would not have had a career
but for playboy because for
a black comic
to be able to play in front of an
integrated audience either in a club or
on television was really unheard of in
the time that he was coming of age and
he would say that playboy gave him the
chance so those issues of race and
personal freedom and
free expression were also i think
integrally related
well i'm going to turn the
podium back over to steve i'm going to
be here all day and all evening and it'd
be my pleasure to visit with any and all
of you during that time so thank you
again
on the morning of december 7 1941
japanese planes with shimon peres
muhammad ali and former senator and
astronaut john glenn
next week in prime time on c-span
next we'll hear personal accounts about
comedian lenny bruce's life and legacy
from people who knew him including his
lawyer his writing collaborator and his
friends
this 40-minute talk is part of a two-day
conference commemorating the recent
acquisition of lenny bruce's archival
collection at brandeis university
our first speaker
martin garbus is one of the important
lawyers of our time
very important in terms of his advocacy
of human rights abroad
whether in the former soviet union
in chile or in the union of south africa
somebody also deeply involved even in
the constitution of post
communist czechoslovakia
at home uh martin garbus has been deeply
involved in issues involving the first
amendment
and in the promotion of the sort of
freedom of expression which is
obviously one of the key themes of our
conference this afternoon
martin garbers has also
had a striking list of celebrity clients
one of whom
we'll be hearing about right now
[Applause]
i'm very sorry
that before
this conference started
you all haven't had a chance to see
either a video or a movie of lenny bruce
to hear all this commentary
about someone you've never seen
or perhaps heard on a dvd
would be like me trying to explain to
someone something about a rembrandt
portrait
that you've never seen or a book that
you've not read
because
none of this can really capture
who he was
and the difference between who he was
and what he became was startling
i first met him in san francisco
before the prosecutions
and before he became to be considered
such an icon
and the most
significant thing
about lenny's personality
was his humility
and that humility followed him
when he was at the top of his game
until the last days of his life
when he was kind of the society really
had forced him to the bottom of his game
he had disdain
for those people who were trying to
elevate him
into exactly the kind of person we're
talking about here
no one would have been more astonished
than he
perhaps me
at
what we see here today
the various analyses
of sentences we also have a
distinguished person
in the audience charlie nesson
who was involved in the united states
supreme court at the time that they
turned down his petition
if charlie were the judge they would
have granted his petition
uh i think that
in order to
i remember when nixon
gave his i am a crook speech
and i said i wish lenny were here
and then when we heard clinton say it's
the definition of what is
i wish lenny would hear
and as we watch donald trump and hillary
i say i wish lenny were here
i think it's important to know what the
atmosphere was one of the things that
christy mentioned
was the diversity of the country how
things can be said now that couldn't be
said before all this is cyclical
when you have a man like trump
it may be that many of the things that
we thought for so long we had gained and
were going to be a permanent part of the
culture became very different
it's interesting to look at bruce and
the time
and the reasons for his prosecution
because what it tells you
is that many of the same things that
were relevant then are relevant to today
the case dealt with the manipulation of
the legal system it dealt with
prosecutorial misconduct it deals with
all the issues
that today as we talk about criminal
reform
surfaced in lenny's trial
the prosecution of leni
was caused by a group in new york of
something called operation yorkville
which was on the east side of manhattan
there was a man named father hill
and he was running around new york
trying to pick up stuff that he thought
was dirty frank hogan was going to run
for office
d.a
and he seized upon operation yorkville
as something to run on the whole
question of obscenity prosecutions etc
now at the time at this time with lenny
you have to look back at the culture to
understand exactly what was going on the
case doesn't arise from nothing at that
time you had to have a license in new
york to show certain kind of films the
licensing boards are prevalent
throughout the united states for example
a film with anna magnani called the
miracle that couldn't be shown in new
york
i was before the supreme court in a case
from ohio
involving involving a genre film which
couldn't be shown in the united states
and of course there was bonnie rossett
and the lawrence and miller prosecutions
but the unique thing about lenny is that
he was alive and there
lawrence wasn't there miller wasn't
there
but i am curious with just the movie
so lenny was a human being
who got caught up in this
and what's important to see
is looking at him
and looking at the times and then just
trying to think about today's times you
saw extraordinary forces in the united
states the sixties were upon us the
reaction to the sixties was upon us
in the da's office though in manhattan
there was enormous resistance to the
prosecution altogether a few da's
refused to prosecute refused to
prosecute they were asked to be part of
the team richard q who was then the
prosecutor
ultimately took it on himself he did it
politically because he wanted to succeed
hogan
and he then ran for the d.a basically on
the basis of the prosecution of lenny
bruce i tried to run in the primary it
was the the bruce case was the keynote
i didn't get very far ultimately robert
morgenthau ran
and he won
the other thing i think that's important
to mention
is that at the trial
seated at the trial and it didn't get
that much attention
lenny didn't become
the icon the hero he was until after the
trial really
sitting at the trial was philip roth who
had not yet written portnoy's complaint
he had written when she was when she was
good and letting go
sitting at the trial was allen ginsburg
who was then an uptight student in
columbia
sitting at the trial was jules pfeiffer
and also sitting at the trial elaine may
mike nichols
and other people who were
extraordinarily influenced by what was
going on what philip said
then and since then that i couldn't have
written portnoy's complaint
uh if lenny had not been there
and ginsburg who i spoke to over the
years also talked about the effect of
lenny on these people it's not the the
immediate effect
and the things that they did
with respect to
lenny's humility sophistication and
unawareness
at the time of the trial
what he wanted to do
was to take the stand and testify the
way the prosecution got the conviction
was not solely on the words
the the d.a was too sophisticated and
new york was too much
of a involved place a committed place
you just couldn't prosecute somebody for
words
so what they did is they sent in someone
called inspector rui
and he went to the trial and he observed
the trial
and then at the trial it became not just
the prosecution for words
inspector ruay got up in the stand
and he gave his notes on what the what
lenny bruce's performance was his note
he was humorless rui was humorless he
was uneducated basically he really had
no sense
of what the performance was
and then what rui did is he took the top
of the microphone and he did something
like this which would be like a priest
making a benediction or a blessing
and rueway translated that into
masturbation
so the result was lenny was convicted
not just because of his words
he was convicted for his physical
conduct as well
uh i could go on as as i told steve for
two hours i don't have two hours
uh so i just want to tell you i hope
that sometime you'll have a chance to
see
some of what lenny actually talked about
when he talked about eleanor roosevelt
or jackie kennedy
the icons of her time
or when he talked about race
i've heard hear conversations comparing
him to mort saul and other people lenny
was unique at that time there was nobody
doing what he did at all
it wasn't dick gregory it wasn't mort
saul
he was a singular voice
and i think the great tragedy
is that he's not here today
thank you
[Applause]
our next speaker is a longtime and
cherished friend of the
archives and special collections at
brandeis university in particular
and it's a pleasure now to welcome arlen
ettinger
thank you steve
when i was asked to be here i wasn't
quite sure what i would speak about
but i realized that as a young teen
three people that certainly influenced
my life
perhaps more than any other
were rosa parks
bob dylan
and lenny bruce
years later when i set out to start an
auction house that
would take a different direction
uh try to incorporate
important collections in the world of
art and collectibles
i never did
lose sight of the inspiration that those
three remarkable people provided for me
the earliest experience i can recall
where
something we did
seemed to make a difference was when a
man came up to me
desperate to raise thirty thousand
dollars to pay hospital bills for his
daughter
he had no money but he had a room full
of about ninety wooden carousel figures
that he described as having gotten as a
boy in the 1930s by hanging around
philadelphia area amusement parks and
watching workmen
intentionally destroy the carousels by
creating bonfires
and he would say something like hey
mister don't burn that horse could i
have it and they would say sure kid why
not
and he gathered these figures in that
way as it turned out a hundred years ago
carousels were the most popular
amusement you could
go to but they had lost favor to more
challenging newer rides
so here we are now 40 some odd years
later and he has these 90 figures
behind his home
and he asked if we would sell them to
help his daughter with the hospital
bills and i took a look at the figures
and knew no more than anyone else there
were no books on the subject at the time
no one knew who carved these figures a
century earlier but they clearly were
fascinating you could see different
carvers hands at work
and and certainly seemed worthy of
preservation
so we began a grassroots research
project to discover who carved these as
it turned out
most of them were carved by eastern
european jewish immigrants who had come
to this country and settled in places
like coney island and philadelphia and
new haven
and created
really these remarkable figures
well we
conducted that auction
and uh the fact that they sold for a
million dollars
was certainly a blessing for our
consignor a wonderful thing for us but
more importantly
following that event
these figures never after
saw the flames of a bonfire they've now
ended up at the smithsonian
many many other museums where they were
very much reflect
a part of our heritage
uh not much after that
i i heard a rumor
about
how the ss united states
the glory of our maritime fleet the
largest ocean liner ever built in the
united states was about to be towed out
to sea
and the contents of its more than 1 000
rooms
dumped overboard in the north atlantic
and i said to myself well how silly is
that
what a crime uh there are certainly
ocean line aboves and maybe more
importantly the tens of thousands of
travelers who
traveled on that ship the loss of this
stuff
uh forgetting the fact of how it was
polluting the ocean
but to dump all that seemed insane so i
went to the owners of the ship
proposed the notion of an auction only
to say we like this idea so much they
took it to our far larger competitors
sotheby's and christie's
those firms as wonderful as they are
claim that it would take 10 years
if you could do that auction at all to
prepare for this monumental task
so the owners of the ship knowing they
had a window of three months
in which to do anything if anything was
to be done they had they had contracted
with the people of haiti
to
remove asbestos that had been discovered
on board the ship
and the haitians were going to be given
the lovely job of removing the asbestos
just at the time asbestos had been
determined to be a carcinogen
so they came the owners of the ship came
back to me and said okay big shot
uh you have three months to do this
auction if you want to do it
well i can tell you the conditions on
board were unbearable the heat was in
excess of 120
degrees at all times it was a 17 deck
ship no elevators were operating you had
to walk up and down to remove any object
from the ship
and i couldn't find anybody
quickly to work
on this task of cataloging
this massive project
so out of desperation someone pointed me
in the direction
of a halfway house
this was in virginia
being lived in by 200 people all of whom
were african-american and all of whom
had just recently been released from
prison that's why they were in a halfway
house
and i went to the director of that house
and said i need your help we need to
hire these people to do this work
it will include counting the silverware
and make no mistake about it every place
setting
for the 5 000 passengers could include
as many as 26 utensils
it wasn't a fish knife that you were
dealing with is what kind of fish knife
that you wanted
but when he and he went on to say that
if i hired these people did i know that
half of them probably had been in jail
for theft
and that i'm going to have them counting
the silverware we're lucky if we had two
spoons left at the end of the day
and i said well that was sort of a
chance we had to take
and we did hire them and i can
assure you it was the most inspirational
thing i've ever been involved in because
these folks
work day and night
around the clock
and today
many many years later i proudly look
back at that event
as the world's largest auction
and stayed friends with these folks
we went on to represent
the rosa parks archive which is now at
the library of congress
and i think it's fair to say would not
have been there had it not because it
was a great feud that had developed
after her death and then how
the courts had asked us to step in and
bring some resolution
to that and now
uh as will become evident in the years
ahead one will see that rosa parks was
very much more than just simply the
little lady who didn't give up her seat
on the bus
but rather
was considering all her life what
difference she could make to change the
world but in any case why am i here
as
a few years ago with a parent of a young
daughter who had started as an
undergraduate at brandeis
somehow the word got to sarah schumacher
who i'm sure is in the room uh
archivist
and head of special collections and
sarah somehow put two and two together
and figured here's a guy who gets
involved in collections could i assist
somehow
in helping the school acquire this most
important archive and it was a
no-brainer kind of question of course i
would do everything i could and uh if i
did a little bit we're very very happy
and pleased that it could be here
delighted to meet kitty bruce my
daughter is graduating this year so it's
a it's a happy day thank you all
[Applause]
thank you arlen
the actuarial tables are very benign
with regard to our next two speakers
both of whom also knew lenny bruce
and it's a pleasure to um to introduce
william carl thomas
and he will speak
next about his own relationship to lenny
bruce when i was 13 i bought a press
camera and became a photojournalist
selling
articles to newspapers and magazines
when i was 19
i was a cocktail pianist in the french
quarter in new orleans i worked for a
man named frank ray pirelli a nightclub
comedian owned a nightclubbing
partnership with another comedian named
shecky green
the
frankie wanted to be
america's federico fellini and he wanted
to write
and direct and produce offbeat films of
social significance and controversy
eventually he did produce 20 films and
four plays and won some awards and more
or less fulfilled his dream
but at that time he was just an aspiring
film writer
he discovered even though he was eight
years older than me he discovered i was
a published photojournalist he asked me
to
write
screenplays with him
and
although our writing was interrupted by
my
uh
years in the service and combat in korea
we ended up in 1956 in hollywood
to continue
our writing
together and
i've discovered then that he would had
become
a mentor a tutor and eventually a
manager to an unknown comic named lenny
bruce
lenny also had film ambitions
and he saw the progress that we were
making
and he asked me to collaborate with him
on a 50 50 basis
to write screenplays we wrote three
screenplays we started to film one of
them but
none of them ever made
he with lenny in the lead role in me as
director of cinematography but now and
i've made it to the screen primarily
because of financial mismanagement
but frankie was ahead of his time and
trying to encourage lenny to
create
comedy records which were a pioneering
venue in that day
and lenny was resistant to the idea but
frankie got fantasy to come down and
record some of uh lenny's performance
and they called a few of his bits and
put them
in a compilation of six comedians in an
album titled interviews about times
but they declined to do a solo album of
lenny because they said his work was too
brief too nebulous and too controversial
now lenny took pride in the fact that it
was controversial but he was
surprised to think that his material was
too nebulous or brief
and frank he said do something so i went
and sat through three of his three
nights of performance with my stopwatch
and my notebook and on the third night
we sat in canters and i explained to
lanny lenny i timed everything
not one of your bits goes over 30
seconds they're all one line as two
lines and three liners frankie and i
laugh at every one of them but the
audience only laughs at about every
third fourth or fifth one
and it's because
either it goes over their head or
it's controversial in there then on the
other side of the controversy
and so i suggested why don't we
if if they think it's too brief and
nebulous why don't we sit down just like
we did with the screenplays and script
routines take these one-liners expand
them into larger
then
routines
was resistant but when
fantasy didn't return calls he agreed to
do it
and just like with the screenplays he'd
get off work to come to my place we'd
write until sunrise
i don't have time to explain
all of the routines by any means uh most
of them are explained in my book there's
a chapter called the creative process
but one of the most important ones that
might
i think be relative to some of the other
speakers today as a routine that's known
as religions incorporated
it began with a one-liner the one-liner
was based on the fact that the pontiff
at that time
pope pius xii
was a man with a thin ascetic face
and a thin large hooked nose
when his picture was on life magazine
cover
lenny decided that he would he'd
put his face close to the mic hold up
the picture and say
you realize of course the pope was
jewish
and it got such a visceral reaction from
the audience fifty percent
left fifty percent were outraged
and it was it was very effective line
and he loved it so he said that's the
first thing that we're going to write
and he and i said i i had a line from a
point my friend had written
that ended up in the poem was about
the difficulty in finding housing during
world war ii and said you can't find a
shack nor a tent or a shed but ain't no
use to shoot yourself dead because they
won't let you go where the angels dwell
and the politicians need all the space
in hell
so
i said we'll we'll take you you die you
go to heaven you're at the pearly gates
saint peter's negotiating with you but
and then saying peter says oh yeah
aren't you the guy that said the pope is
jewish
and then you have this great debate
with
saint peter about that line and we can
really build that
we kicked it around for a little while
didn't use it on that line we used it
later on a routine called
showbiz heaven
but
the line still hung there
and what really was the catalyst for it
was that i had a bunch of dog-eared
paperback thrift store books
of the authors of that day anne rand
phillip wiley john steinbeck pearl
bought vance packet
lenny
didn't read much in those days later he
read thought books voraciously to defend
himself
but back then he read variety and
hollywood reporter and that was about it
he'd
thumb through these books at my place
and he made me give him a critique about
the book or the author and he'd really
irritate me by saying
taking snap judgments that anne ran was
a dyke
philip wiley was a [ __ ]
john steinbeck was a hawk
and pearl buck was sexually repressed
but he couldn't get a handle on vance
packet because it was non-fiction and he
kept making me go further into books
like the power elite and the hidden
persuaders and
when i had used the term
madison avenue boardroom about 10 times
finally he had an epiphany and he put
his fingers up to make a director's
frame
and said that's it
all religious leaders are on madison
avenue in the boardroom
planning next year's religious hustle
and uh
oral roberts is presiding and there's
billy billy graham and bishop sheen and
norman vincent peale and rabbi weiss and
and all the religious leaders of the day
it was a natural because those religious
leaders of that day all had television
shows
all had
top ratings
and they also
held a tremendous amount of power
and
they used that power in a very
conservative fashion endorsing
conservative politicians
so
the thing kind of
wrote itself and of course
the pope is jewish that line
ended up as the capper because at the
end of this board meeting where a lot of
stuff that i don't have time to go
through it
occurred he gets a phone call from the
pope
yes a yes operator i'll accept the
charges
and
and
no uh
yeah billy graham wants i know if you
can get him one of those ferraro cars
and uh and on and on with the pope
and then the capital the whole routine
is the very last line
where he
looks around suspiciously and says don't
worry they don't know you're jewish
that routine
was
just sparked to a lot of other routines
that we did
the the second coming of
um
a lot of other routines that were based
on
religion are based on the power elite
that
uh religious and political leaders who
were hypocrites and and lenny was the
little boy who said that
the emperor wore no clothes so the end
result was that
all those routines
were actually created
we wrote for three months
and those material in those three months
became the bulk of the material in the
first three fantasy albums and the stuff
that we wrote and it didn't work and we
put it on the shelf
we dug it out years later and it became
material from later years
now
i don't mean to challenge the idea that
lenny
wrote his own material
frankie wrote gag lines for lenny
frankie taught lenny
the harder to impersonate voices
we are all made of the talents of those
people we've been exposed to and who
have helped us along the way
the material for those three albums
with some of the best writing i ever did
subsequently i wrote 12 books i've got
frankie's biography coming out soon
it'll be the 13th one
but
uh
we are all part of
of other people's uh training
and lenny was
unique in that he gave voice
to so many things that the public at
large
wanted to say and didn't have a platform
to say
and he said it in their language
in their time
with the complete honesty of their
their
disenchantment with their leadership
so
it was my privilege if you want more
details about some of the other routines
they're in my book
lenny bros the making of a prophet
and um
i'll be happy to answer any questions
after this
thank you so much
our next speaker is susan silver
a comedy writer for the mayor mary tyler
moore show for maude for bob newhart and
others an npr commentator it's a
pleasure to welcome susan here to the
platform
[Applause]
it's really an honor to be here um
i recently lost a very dear friend of
more than 40 years who happened to be
marty garbas's best friend his name was
gary marshall he was my mentor and my
manager and he was a comedy icon too and
he used to say he wanted to be the
recess in the school day of comedy he
wanted to be the light fun no heavy
message not serious academic kind of
thing and i look around at all of you
serious brilliant academicians and so
i'm the recess of this conference
because the reason i'm here is lenny
bruce's mother fixed me up with him when
i was in college
and i want to go like this and say i'm
blonde but
um
one other thing gary said
in show business we have a term that's
called hyphenates you're a director
slash producer a writer slash director
an actor slash waiter usually
anyway um when i retired from show
business i got very involved with
holocaust related things i worked for
the anti-defamation league i ran their
speaker's bureau and i was the un
observer for the simon wiesenthal center
so gary said i was the original
hyphenate sitcom writer slash nazi
hunter
so i guess i do fit in here because i
see we have panels on the holocaust and
humor
um
i've just finished my memoir about being
a woman in a man's world about being a
woman
writing in
the sort of beginning of feminism where
comedy changed because hopefully of mary
tyler moore
but another thing in my book is i'm like
zelig
and i i should say mizzy like i have
encountered in my life every icon of my
generation it's kind of scary i was in
show business i was in politics and i'm
kind of always in the right place at the
right time and as you can see i'm not
very shy so it all worked out very well
um we have to remember as as christie
said the times we were living in this
was the early 60s i'm much older than i
look
um
and it was a time where don't forget on
television married couples were not even
allowed to be shown in the same bed they
had to sleep in separate beds we didn't
even really know what feminism was until
1970 or 1962 when when betty friedan
wrote her book
and i grew up in a double bind of that i
grew up in milwaukee wisconsin which is
about as
midwest a person you could be and when i
grew up all my friends wanted to go to
college to get their mrs
or they'd be a teacher i wanted to go to
hollywood and be a writer but being an
only child in a jewish protective home i
wasn't allowed to cross the main street
until i was 12.
so i could only get to northwestern my
first two years
and then i escaped to hollywood to
california sim city
i had an uncle out there who was also a
famous writer director producer and man
about town his name was psy howard and i
was living with him if my parents only
knew what it was like there they never
would have sent me but that's another
story which we'll have a reference to
lenny in a minute
um
in doing research on lenny since i was
going to be speaking from my personal
experience i found a really great
article he did for playboy in 1963 about
what would happen if you had to play in
milwaukee
and of course i wouldn't have been
allowed to see them but i just want to
read a few pages of this articles it's
it's so great and it also shows how
strange it was for this little
jewish virgin to meet lenny bruce
let's say i'm working at the crescendo
and he says you know i'll finish a show
some guy will come up to me and say i'm
i'm a club owner i'd like you to work
for me it's a beautiful club you ever
work in milwaukee
lots of people you know there i mean
you'll do great you'll kill them you'll
have a lot of fun do you bowl
the only thing is i know that those
clubs between los angeles and new york
the people in the audience are a little
older than me the most i can say to
people over 50 is thank you i've had
enough to eat
so i get to milwaukee the first thing
that frightens me to death is they've
got a 6 30 dinner show
and this was the home of my parents were
always talking about the early bird
special
6 30 lenny says in the afternoon people
are going to a nightclub it's not even
dark yet
i don't want to go in the house it's not
dark yet man if the dinner show is held
up it's only because the jello is not
hard
the people look familiar but i've never
been to milwaukee before
then i realized these are the gray lines
sightseeing bus tours before they leave
it's where they come from
they're like 40 year old chicks with
prom gowns on
they don't laugh they don't heckle they
just stare at me in disbelief and there
are walkouts every night the owner says
to me well i never saw you do that
religious bit and those words you use
the chef is confused the desserts aren't
moving
i go to the men's room i see kids in
there kids four years old kids the kids
are in awe of the men's room this is the
first time they've been in a place their
mother isn't allowed to go in
come on out no uh-uh i'm going to come
in and get you no you're not allowed in
here because everybody's doing making
wet in here
in between the shows i'm a walker i'm
getting nervy nervous and nudgy the
owner decides to cushion me in his next
introduction ladies and gentlemen the
star of our show lenny bruce he's
incidentally a gi an xgi a hell of a
good performer folks a great kidder you
know it's all a bunch of silliness up
here he doesn't mean what he says
he kids about the ho the pope about
jewish religion about colored people
white people it's silly it's a
make-believe he's a hell of a nice guy
he was at the veterans hospital today
for a show he did a show for the boys
here he is his mother's here he's
probably
he's probably from here she lives here
in town really
now a joke is a joke right folks what
the hell i wish that you'd try to
cooperate whoever has been sticking ice
picks in the tires outside it's not
funny
now lenny may kid about narcotics
homosexuality things like that and he
gets walkouts
so that's the world i came from
and there i was this little scared
jewish virgin
the night i met lenny bruce
so this is there's only one person who
has their own chapter in my book of all
the famous people that's lenny bruce
this is my chapter on lenny
it's new year's eve 1964 1965 i can't
remember
i was out with a group of friends at
someone's house and a lively older woman
was entertaining us
she was sally marr a former stripper but
best known as the mother of lenny bruce
lenny the brilliant but troubled
comedian single-handedly changed comedy
with his stream of consciousness his
cultural critique he didn't tell jokes
he told truths dramatic looking with
dark soulful eyes and a sad smile he was
someone i admired
and yes had a crush on
imagine my joy and alarm
when lenny's mother took a liking to me
and said you should meet my son i'm
going to call him and tell him to come
to the party
what
lenny bruce controversial potentially
dangerous
possibly druggy coming to meet a jewish
virgin
okay as long as no one tells my mother
his mother did call him and he came i
wondered why he didn't have a better
place to be on new year's eve
he walked in and it was smitten at first
sight on my side at least i sat at his
feet with a bunch of other girls as he
mulled different topics he pointed to
the angels peeking out from the filigree
borders of the ceiling according to
lenny they now look shocked as they
listen to him
we thought this was a brilliant
observation have not having not even
noticed them ourselves
everything he said was brilliant and by
the end of the evening i was in love or
some crush-like facsimile thereof
he asked for my number and said maybe i
could come down to his show the
following week at the club he played in
hollywood called the crescendo
i said yes of course
then i called my uncle by that time i
was living in an apartment but i
remained close to him and he said no way
this guy is way too dangerous for you i
asked why
he listed about ten reasons
and then he said if i insisted on going
out with lenny bruce he was coming along
as chaperone
and he did
he went with me to the show which was
racy a little scary and amazing my uncle
really admired lenny i was kind of glad
that he had accompanied me because now i
was really scared to death the secret
garden beckoned
we waited at the bar when lenny emerged
we all had a drink
he and my uncle got along famously i sat
there not saying a word out of my
element and when he went and he wrote
something on a napkin and he handed it
to me with a smile
it was a little drawing an arrow with
writing along
before it went around and it said
susan will go to the corner but she's
afraid to go around
wow was it that evident
after we talked to wow who went
backstage and brought out a few pages of
one of his routines and gave them to me
he signed it clark gable found a live in
argentina love lenny bruce
it turned out to be the famous bit about
how to make your colored friends
comfortable at parties you're supposed
to drop names like uncle ben oh i love
that rice aunt jemima oh the maple syrup
you dropped that into the conversation
it was classic and became a collector's
item
which i never would have sold of course
years later it was stolen from my house
in california
i was shocked when not too long after
our date lenny bruce died he odd in a
gruesome way alone in his bathroom
he had been dating another jewish
college girl named lotus weinstock who
was a comic
my uncle couldn't stop from saying i
told you so
frankly thank god he had or who knows
what kind of trouble i'd have gotten
into
but truth be told
i wanted to take care of him he had the
most soulful eyes he was so gentle
and he was a gentleman
he knew that he scared me to death and
he gave me a graceful way out
now a few years later i worked with mort
saul who we've talked about mort was not
a sweet soul
he still isn't um he's still on he's on
twitter now doing his routine in a chair
it's bizarre anyway i i worked for six
months i was the i started i was
assistant by the end of the six months
everybody ahead of me had been fired and
i was the producer of his talk show
because you weren't allowed to talk when
mort talked or you weren't allowed to do
anything that annoyed him we we became
friends later but anyway mort told the
story how he and lenny used to work
together upstairs and downstairs of a
club and half the time lenny was
arrested so mort had to go and do his
show both places
then later in my career i worked with
marvin worth who was kind of the
take care of of the estate of lenny and
he produced the movie
in which dustin hoffman did a good job
but i always wanted to tell marvin who
thought lenny was the sweetest kindest
person he ever knew dustin hoffman was
not nearly as sexy as lenny was
[Applause]
this weekend on american history tv on
c-span 3
this afternoon just before 5 eastern
architecture